yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jen here
as you know I absolutely loved
Zootopia and each time I watch the movie
I find something new to enjoy but
because of the way animated movies are
made there's often tons of incredible
stuff that the animators work on which
doesn't make it into the final film so
in this video I'm going to be taking a
look at the dozens of amazing deleted
scenes and rejected ideas from Zootopia
that hit the cutting room floor and a
quick warning this of course there are
spoilers ahead so if you want to avoid
any spoilers click here for my spoiler
free review I'll come back after you've
seen the movie just before I get started
I've got another fantastic copy of this
gorgeous hardback book the artists who
topless to give away all you have to do
is subscribe and leave a comment about
the deleted scenes on this video to give
you an idea of what you can look forward
to in the book there's tons of amazing
concept art sketches and information
that give an incredible peek into the
making of the movie first up is the
movies opening scene which sets up Judy
to become a police officer in Zootopia
although in a different way than we see
in the final movie the alternate opening
is set in woodlands elementary school
rather than at the carrot Days Festival
and his duty practicing a song with her
classmates while their teacher mrs.
armadillo accompanies them on the piano
Judy's friends each sing a line about
what they want to be when they grow up
but when it comes to Judy's turn she
won't sing that she wants to grow
carrots this opening establishes how
animals are stereotyped for example
Sally the squirrels things that she
wants to sell nuts
I'm Rory the raccoon sings that he wants
to drive a trash truck but Judy proves
she's capable of other things when Bobby
Catmull the Cougar cub is about to fall
out of a tree
Judy grabs mrs. armadillos laser pen and
gets Bobby to chase its light down the
tree to safety a police officer then
arrives and gives Judy a junior zpd
badge and says she should become a
police officer and when Judy's
classmates scoffs that she's just a
bunny
the officer replies this is Zootopia
where anyone can be anything a moment
which echoes what Judy does and says to
Finnick
later in the movie other elements from
this alternate opening scene also
appeared in a slightly different form in
the final movie Bobby Catmull appears as
a cougar who creates the various sound
effects during Judy's performance at
carrot days
mrs. armadillo is the landlady of Judy's
apartment complex and the scene in the
alternate opening which features a deer
being mock attacked by a predator as
part of the rehearsals for the school
show mirrors both the dramatic scene
Judi performs is fake blood in the
opening of the final movie and also the
final movie's climactic showdown when
Nick fakes turning savage to catch
bellwether since Zootopia came out
they've been tons of fans shipping Judy
and Nick and an incredible amount of fan
art on just that subject so shippers of
Nick and Judy everywhere will likely
love this next scene I'm going to talk
about this scene would have appeared in
the movie just after everyone's favorite
Fox and Bunny tea with scape man chassé
who's gone savage in the seeing Judy and
Nick arrived at her very pink apartment
which prompts Nick to question Judy's
description of where they were going as
a safehouse
Judy's reply that it's a safe house with
a space in the middle a house that is
safe is a fantastic riff on Nick's
earlier words to Judy that he was not
falsely advertising the red word he sold
the rodents and it was actually redwood
with a space in the middle wood that is
red Judy's family have come to the big
city to pay her a surprise visit and
when Judy's for the first season ik he
asked her to pass him the Fox taser and
then worries that Nick is actually her
boyfriend the family also discovers in
this scene that judy is a meter maid not
a real cop as she led them to believe so
her father demands that she leaves
Zootopia and returned home with them but
Nick steps in to defend her in the final
movie this moment was replaced with
chief BOGO rather than her father trying
to make Judy leave the police force
there's some really amazing designs for
Judy's family home in bunny borough that
didn't make it into the final film the
huge size of Judy's family and house was
going to be a major feature in the film
with over 200 bunnies running around in
fact originally Judy's family was so
large that her father couldn't even
remember her name
also the family home was going to be
centered around a constantly in use
kitchen and a dining area that rotated
slowly allowing new hungry bunnies to
take the place of bunnies who'd already
finished eating and the bunny borough
district was also going to feature more
of the Totoro inspired buildings we only
saw briefly in the final film at the
bunny burrow train station during the
chase seen through little rodentia you
might have spotted a billboard for the
fast food restaurant Shea cheese in an
early draft of the movie Finnick would
take the drive-through orders making use
of his giant ears to do so while Nick
worked cleaning the cheese filters in
this version of the movie clawhauser was
also a delivery cheater for the
restaurant making deliveries to the
district's rodents
Shh YZ was going to tell the story of
how Nick and Finnick met the movie's
co-director Jared Burgess said this was
his favorite deleted location and that
he'd love to see a short film featuring
the fast food joint another part of a
joint which didn't appear in the end
film was bug burger which is were suto
cos predators would go to eat because
predators don't eat other animals in
Zootopia to get their protein they eat
insects so bug burger served up
grasshopper shakes cricket chips and
Secada burgers there is a tiny reference
to bug burger in the final film in the
scene where Nick is leading Judy through
an alleyway shortcut and there are some
bug burger fast food boxes listed on the
ground originally there was going to be
more of Nick's backstory explored in the
film including a scene where we get to
see Nick as a cub with his father it's a
touching moment where Nick's father goes
with his son to pitch a business idea
for a loan so he can start his own
family tailoring shop called suit topia
this scene wasn't used as it was part of
the initial idea for the film where the
story was told from Nick's perspective
as a central character rather than
through Judy's eyes we know Nick has
always had an entrepreneurial mind for
this popsicle business but in an early
version of the Tokyo just like his
father Nick went to the Zootopia banks
to pitch a business idea but Nick's idea
was for an entertainment venue called
wild times in a scene which actually got
so far in the process that it was voiced
by Jason
man Nick explained his idea to all the
city's bankers who just happened to all
be prey
it's a funny scene where Nick visits
banks like lemming brothers borrow
borough JPMorgan and slaughter and
brothers and gets rejected every time
eventually Nick ends up visiting the
polar bear gangster boss Kozlov who
loans him the money the designs for wild
times were well advanced before the idea
was abandoned wild times was an indoor
arcade where predators could let their
instincts noose ELISA the amusement park
featured a huge range of games and rides
for example there was a roller coaster
called the rora coaster where predators
could roar and be themselves by the way
there's a glimpse of what might have
been the building for wild times in the
scene where judy goes to find Nick by
the small stone bridge Kozlov who Nick
takes a loan from to finances wild times
arcade did appear in the final movie is
the Polar Bear who carries mr. big in
his hands when Nick and Judy have been
caught by Kevin and Raymond in earlier
versions though he ran the Mafia in
tundra town and he owned a restaurant
called kosnov's palace which served as a
front for his shady operations the
design of the interior of kosnov's
palace used warm colors to contrast with
the icy blue and white of the cold
exterior the scene we see in the final
movie of Nick and Finnick hustling Judy
into paying for their jumbo park is a
much revised version from an earlier
version of the movie that early
alternates seen in Jumbo's cafe shows
Nick claiming that his son has a
condition called pachyderm yaw Percy
which according to Nick means that his
son thinks he's an elephant Nick and
Finnick put on a hilarious performance
with Nick begging the ice-cream parlor
owner not to break his son's heart when
he refuses to serve him what he wants
and then to cap it all Nick claims he
left his wallet at the orphanage Nick
senses Judy's fallen for his scheme so
lays the sob story on even further which
ends up in Judy pulling out her cash to
pay it's still very funny as it displays
Nick and Phenix conman skills although
judy probably comes off a bit more naive
and silly in this version than in the
final movie
in the final film after Judy discovers
she was hustled by Nick she goes back to
her apartment feeling really fed up and
gets a call from her parents who
discovers she's just a meter maid
there's an earlier and longer version of
this scene while we see Judy travel back
to the apartment on the subway getting
squashed by two larger animals in this
version after discarding her microwaved
carrots for one she goes to call him mum
but stops herself however the phone
accidentally dials and she ends up
talking to her parents and her
grandfather who's very prejudiced
Leanne's foxes in this version her
parents don't realize she's just a meter
maid
which makes Judy feel really guilty for
hiding the truth from them it's a much
sadder version of the scene than the one
in the movie and ends with Judy curling
up on her bed among her cuddly toys by
the way Judy's grandfather pop-pop is
the rabbit we see at the train station
in the final movie the one who bears a
very close resemblance to call from up
there's a deleted scene in which Judy
starts her investigation into the
missing otter Emmitt Otterton by using
the office and computer of an elephant
cop who's away on vacation it's a fun
scene where judy has to make the most of
her agility to use a computer that's way
bigger than she is the scene was edited
out of the final movie to keep the
film's pace up and to show Judy getting
her lead on a certain by working more
closely with clawhauser designs for a
rough biker style bar for sheep were
developed although the location didn't
make it into the final film the bar was
called the cloven hoof and it was set in
a sleazy part of town it's likely that
we would have seen Durgan as a bad sheep
like Jesse and Walter hanging out there
the filmmakers also had plans for a
nocturnal district which was going to be
an area of caves underneath the city
where nocturnal animals like bats would
live in the end Zootopia story didn't
require the locations and the idea
wasn't fully developed however it might
be linked to the bat eyewitness figure
who appears together with clawhauser in
Zootopia character packs and who's
described as visiting clawhauser at the
police station quite frequently is he
often witnesses crimes the Meadowlands
is another district we never got to see
properly it's basically a broad
grassland area where the sheep and
grazing
animals live we did get a tiny peek at
the edge of the Meadowlands though as
the cliffside Asylum is just on the
border in an early draft of the movie
there was a sheep conspiracy where sheep
would disguise themselves as wolves to
deliberately incriminate predators
making them look dangerous if you'd like
to find out about one of the Sheep
characters called wooly who used to do
that and check out my video on Zootopia
deleted characters another location that
didn't make it into the final film was
outback Island which was home to
Australian animals such as kangaroos
koalas platypuses and dingoes here all
together were known as out backers this
location was cut as it didn't fit the
main story although it does appear in
the book Zootopia the stinky cheese
caper and other cases from the zpd files
there was an additional scene at the
Natural History Museum which was cut
from the film due to time constraints
the cut scene featured bellwether making
a speech to Judy about the origins of
Zootopia those origins relate back to a
painting which if you're extremely
eagle-eyed you can glimpse in the museum
as well as a subway station the painting
shows lions and zebras shaking paws and
agreeing to predators and prey living in
peace while giving the speech in the
scene bellwether looks out and talks
about the fountain in the square which
represents the watering hole around
which the animals bonded when they
declared peace although we do get to see
the palm Hotel and Casino on the train
ride that judy takes into the city when
she arrives there were also extensive
designs and scenes storyboarded inside
the hotel that did not get used the
design of the hotel was inspired by
super luxurious hotels in Dubai and
ghazal had a penthouse apartment there a
scene with Judy and Nick falling down
the side of the hotel while escaping
from a round was storyboarded but
dropped in favour of the scene in the
rainforest district where Judy and Nick
fall through the vines while escaping
from the savage Manchus an earlier
version of the movies action-packed
finale was set in a large stadium called
zoo teneal Stadium there was going to be
a spectacular Olympic game style opening
show called an Amalia which showcased
the history of Zootopia it was going to
feature gazelle who's a prey animal
worming with their predator backup
dancers and they were going to be flying
squirrels and pigs and animals shot out
of confetti cannons and that huge show
would have acted as the backdrop for the
movie's climactic showdown the film did
of course end with gazelle performing
with her Tiger dancers at a pop concert
but that was after Judy and Nick had
already caught the baddies so guys do
you think any of those deleted scenes or
ideas should have been in the final
movie and what would you like to see in
a Zootopia sequel I can't wait to hear
your thoughts in the comments below and
don't forget to subscribe and comment
for your chance to win this beautiful
hardback book the art of zootropolis if
you enjoyed this video check out my
other Zootopia videos including 7
awesome characters who are deleted from
the movie 25 things you didn't know
about the making of Zootopia and also
coming shortly I'll have a brand new
Easter Egg video you'll be able to find
all of those right here in my full
Zootopia video playlist thanks for
watching and see you next time if you go
a movie lovers